[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
ah what a lad well today i have someone
who i've been trying to get on for a
very long time but having recently
played his 100th game for the hurricanes
and becoming the oldest player to ever
play super rugby now was the perfect
time and i won't read all the teams that
he's played for over his career because
it will take up too much time but let's
just say he has had an incredibly
successful 19-year career in this
wonderful game but what everyone will
know this man for who has played with
him will know he's one of the real
characters of the game and you do not
find many better lads in this man it is
the great ben may welcome lad
jeez that's a big intro mate that's a
good
yeah thanks for um speaking kindly i
mean not many do
mate it's great to have you on i know we
got close a couple of times early on in
season one but um we're here now great
to have you on
yeah man i just had a kid i think and uh
big old change for the old dad
i've been 19 years of footy i've been
the most selfish human on the planet i'm
unsure how i managed to find a wife but
uh
anyway you've got there and you've got
your beautiful daughter how's it all
how's it all been time away from her
locked away in um queenstown yeah it's
not too yeah it's difficult you know
what it's like when you got kids but um
no it's all good mate i don't have to
cook any feeds and
i've got my own room and i don't have to
wake up and do anything with the kids so
it's not too bad yeah
what are you being up to when you wee
bubble how how restricted is it there in
queenstown oh hugely restrictive
no well i've actually got a business
up at another business helps outfitters
and um we've got a farm down here
that we run and uh yeah i've been
whipping out there the the main roll is
a meter and a half from
anyone else and wearing a mask so
that's that's relatively easy on a farm
so you just shoot off
yeah i just take the work wagon out
there and do a full day's work on my own
what about training
yeah no train but you know days off
sundays and wednesdays i didn't actually
expect to play down here so i thought
i'd get more time out there next month
i'm having a bloody uh strip up
strip up for your 100th game though mate
what a what an achievement that was how
was how was the week leading up to that
you you mentioned you didn't expect to
be playing but once you were named what
was that like well i haven't played
decent footy for a couple of years
obviously i retired
and uh it's just been dairy farming so i
um
i had a
okay
uh the first week i literally thought i
was gonna end up in um icu
um but then i ended up playing a couple
of pre-seasons and i thought i went
pretty i thought i went pretty average
and then
all of a sudden my name gets ready out
to play the crusaders round one and i
was like oh my heart just dropped
me
um so i sort of quickly
went into
the playbook and thought i need to sort
this out i need to be good
you mentioned you retired a couple of
years earlier when did you decide that
um you were gonna give it another crack
you're gonna join the canes for the
pre-season
now well alfie called me up i was on the
tractor about to go and fix a couple of
fences and he calls me up which he often
does just for
well i wouldn't say coaching mentor but
just to run a few things past me and i
just thought it was one of those chats
and then we had that chat and then he
says oh what
what are you up to so i'm just going to
fix a couple of fences off here and he
says um
well how's the body this is yeah no man
as it is when you retire everything
feels good
and um he's like oh yeah um
well
just a question arie frank's has just
done his achilles um
would you come in for a week or so and i
was like
no way elf
and you know and then i saw anyway we
finished that convo and then
i think he rang me back the next day and
was like you know seriously about that
thing bam do you reckon you could come
in also mate
well i said oh look if you actually if
you desperately need me i'll come in you
know that so
here i am and was 99 a big part of that
decision well yeah i had to not to sleep
on it and then i thought [ __ ] maybe i
should maybe i should have said yeah
yeah i'm keen
uh and this was in december you see and
i thought okay it can't hurt me too much
in a month pre-season
you know it's not like the old days the
old eight weeks of just grinding
um
it turns out you can hurt someone in a
weekly loan a month
how was the pre-season looked like you
were holding your own in there in the
videos i saw mate i actually smashed the
surf to peak did you best ever
obviously you got to run at the start
yeah i came from the back on the run and
then
i smoked the bike won the bike did you
shut and that got me you know what that
does it puts you that puts you for the
hill run ready to go
just got gassed on the hill oh mate i
think i got about 10th oh yeah that is
pretty good though which is pretty good
out of uh
well you know yourself there's um yeah
and especially at your age mate 39 still
going strong and you're still doing like
the wrestling sessions and
you know the old cog breathing
techniques and all that sort of stuff in
your pre-season
yeah none of the breathing stuff mate
just the just a lot of a lot of bashing
each other and running is that no ball
in the pre-season oh yeah well we did
this year because obviously we only had
four weeks and you got to hit the ground
running so we had to do a lot of ball
stuff but they also added a lot of
contact ready stuff in which i struggled
with
but uh got me here got me here got me
through that first game so happy yeah
and how was the game obviously against
the crusaders the team you started with
and
mate bringing up your hundredth at
foresight bar what was it like oh it was
what every kid dreams of but i was so
geeked and i wanted to be really good
that i pretty much didn't do anything
i ran around
i was inaccurate at ruck time i just
actually had a review with gibber and
he's like
what were you thinking about and i was
like mate
i think i got a little bit emotional and
tied up in in the occasion he goes yeah
well it looked like that you've actually
you've been effective at bugger all
right
so
hopefully i um get a chance to redeem
myself on a on a chill level
did you touch that ball that question
came in a few times the one they checked
oh i don't think i did and i think i
would have to be a better athlete to
have touched it because it was down at
the bootlegs wasn't it
i don't think i got a finger on that one
oh true absolute heartbreak because that
was a massive turning point in the game
wasn't it yeah there was a few yeah you
could tell it was brendan pickerel's
first game couldn't you it was
very indecisive
i shouldn't say that brennan's a great
rich oh mate it's a tough job it's a
very tough job shout out to brendan
doing a great job as a referee you know
they are
yeah
how's the boys looking how's the
environment been uh it's been good mate
yeah but when you lose the crusaders
it's never
ha ha happy week after it so
um we've been into our work today and
tomorrow's gonna be a bit of a grind i'd
say so
but you know the boys are really good so
we weren't far off um i'm sure we'll
sort it
surely but make the oldest player to
ever play super rugby what a what an
achievement that is how does that sit
with you
it's quite demoralizing that i did it
was better when no one actually knew my
age because everyone sort of puts me
around that 35 mark yeah
but
yeah
now that it's all come out in the open
people like what is going on the guy's
like 40.
so um i think i've sort of flown under
that 35 radar for about 10 years yeah
good skin care
yeah yeah exactly but now it's been um
oh i guess any record when you're from
when you grow up in merchants a good one
[Laughter]
how have you done it how have you have
you played the game for so long 39
almost 40 like literally is there any
secrets or anything like
well this is kt kt asked me this after
the game and i said mate i don't think
you choose longevity it chooses you
because
i've had heaps of mates like yourself
that would well still want to be playing
footy we don't all just one day go oh
bugger and i've had a guts full yeah
it's normally the body that lets you
down isn't it so um
you're just
you know me i just train like everyone
else every day and
um i just haven't had that many bad
injuries i've had a knee reconstruction
and things early on but
yeah obviously just have robust
genetics
but you have always done all the things
in your sort of prehab and stuff your
body's always in great shape mate you've
got hardly any skin folds over your body
for a prop mat you're you're shredded um
do you think that's been a part of it or
it's genuinely been a bit of
oh it could be mate yeah like you're
saying i love it i love training so
yeah um you know i'm always training and
even on my days off i don't
i don't like to relax i go hunting all
day and uh sometimes i do that side
i've had a few weeks when you were in
the team where i was getting told off
because i was absolutely wrecked on a
thursday
from from hunting trips um
but no no i don't think i train any
harder than anyone else man i think it's
just
genuinely good luck and um
and
yeah
i guess perseverance too i've had a few
injuries where i could have pulled pin
but
obviously love the game so
the rehab's tough i know cozy struggles
he has that many rehab you know what
it's like rehabbing it's like
six weeks of the worst crap training you
could possibly get through
um so that some people do get sick of
that nice i see why yeah fair enough and
is this you done you think is is this
the last hurrah for you
definitely mate i've got other
obligations now kirsty and i are uh
into the dairy farming now and i need to
focus on that um i've been lucky enough
she let me come and play this
hundredth game and maybe a few more
until he gets back but you know i
definitely won't be back next year mate
you've said that that many times
yeah
i'm thinking by the boys twice already
and they've hacked me out so i feel bad
do you think you'll get one more
surely
[Music]
oh it must get to the point it must get
to the point where it's like oh come on
bam that's there's only so many hackers
we can give you
yeah i don't think they will harken me
at this time i'm hoping to get team man
of the year again just to round that off
we pretty much got both hands on that
trophy between me and you yeah how many
times are you up to now you must be up
to about five
oh no i wasn't as many as you but i i
think i've had at least three
um
yeah
hell of a lad mate love it and you've
been massive for that so but we're
speaking like um the canes have been
your only side that you've played for
but mate you've played for almost every
team in new zealand
but like always you mentioned murchison
before i do want to know a little bit
more about what your life was like
growing up 39 years ago give us a bit of
a rundown
hard to remember actually jimmy
no it was um oh just like every country
kid grew up on the farm
uh and loved it we had plenty of um
scope when i was a young fella
but i always did want to get out
and thankfully my parents sent me to
nelson college whereas which is where i
sort of
ran into you blokes
you were way before me
i was still at primary school
yeah okay okay
didn't i coach you and your brother or
something you coached tommy mentioned
the other night he was um i think he was
12 yeah and you were yeah right you were
playing for the market
yeah so no no mitchell was great but i
sort of left there went to nelson boys
and never went back um obviously i'll go
back there and
see family and friends and
do quite a bit of hunting but um it was
always a dream of mine to get out of
there and uh
i always wanted to play for the
crusaders obviously growing up in
mexican your crusader one-eyed
fan but i didn't actually think it was
possible obviously i don't think many
kids do were you good at rugby
not particularly no
by all accounts you're a back were you
to start kicking goals in all sorts yeah
yeah i did i played for buller
as a second five and i kicked the goals
i was actually a good goalkeeper believe
it or not
i also opened the bowling for bulla
i was a quick bowler um
and then um
yeah i had a big growth spurt at school
uh right at the end there and um
yeah things sort of went from there it
was it was one of the biggest growth
spurts
humans will ever see
i probably grew about 80 kilos
well you're still at 12 what what age
were you here
hello this is at the end of school in
the high school yeah so you'd moved into
the front row yeah no i'd move to number
eight and i stayed there i played number
eight when i left school and i went to
i took a building
apprentice
ship down in christchurch and i played
number eight down there um
for a club side called ashley
um that richard lowe was involved with
and then i ended up playing canterbury
19s and and um rob penny said geez
you're not bad at number eight mate um
but i can't see you going any further
with your rugby unless you uh
play prop yeah and i was like because i
was pretty good at number eight actually
because i was a big man
i was about 115 kilo
and i uh and i used to just take it off
the scrum as soon as i seen the nut
and um
you know i was down pretty good but he
yeah he said that and i i didn't take
any notice i was like there's no way i'm
playing prop son i'm wrestling
um
and a year later i sort of
the writing was on the wall uh i was in
the canterbury academy which was lucky
and then
mike krohn actually took me aside and
said hey look i can i can help you son
come you come with me for three months
true and just learnt the craft of a
front rower
yeah yeah i think um i think you're born
a front row mentally though
or every front row i know is not quite
right up top um so if you've got that
attribute
you'll you'll go a long way because
you have to go into some weird dark
places to um to want to do it yeah so so
going back to how you got massive like
what did you say you put on like 80 kgs
how did that happen maybe not 80 but i
you know i would have been a
high score would have been
oh
maybe
75 80 kilo and then by the time i was 18
i was about 110.
but i do have big jeans i think i was a
late bloomer you know like a late
developer yeah
what were you doing how are you getting
so big we're just smashing the gym well
no i had growing pains in all sorts so i
i didn't do gym
it was just hostile food which we you
but you mean no you don't get much of
that no
it was literally a late bloomer puberty
and um
and just normal growth i had growth
pains in my knees and elbows and
i grew into a bit of a giant yeah so
when did you turn into a shredded giant
oh i never really carried much fat no
no i never have
so that's got nothing to do with your um
training as a young kid or creatine or
supplements or anything like that
steroids no
no well you're
we get tested quite a bit to me so
um
no i've never been oh yeah maybe i
probably did have a phase there i think
we all did it sort of into high school
where you're into the protein powder and
the creatine but the creatine never
really did anything it blew me up like
yeah that really made them that really
turned me into a tank
so i had to lay off that because i
couldn't run
but um
yeah and i just
well once i made that canterbury academy
i put on quite a bit of muscle because
we were doing
weights and carry-on before work and
then back in the in the afternoon and
geez it was like she was gonna quit that
it was too much for me after three years
i was like i ain't gonna make this i'm
done here but um luckily
on the stroke of that i made uh
what did i oh i think robbie dean he's
called me on the building site actually
so i was you know so i played for nelson
bays this was while you're in the
academy was that yeah while i was in the
enemy and then i went home and i played
a season for canterbury b because they
made canterbury said don't you go come
back oh yeah
and then i um
made crusaders
um wider training out of canterbury b oh
okay like she told robbie dean's rung me
i was on the building site in
christchurch and i thought one of the
boys was playing a prank on me because
robbie's got a bit of a lisp
like jaunty
yeah
and he's and he rings me and he's like
oh god bennett it's rob dean's here um
just want to inform the you that you're
um you've made the crusaders wider
training group and i was like who who
the f is this
one because you know i had lots of mates
like yourself who played pranks on me
and i basically called him like just
wouldn't wouldn't have his convo and and
he hung up he said i'll tiny thought
we'll be in touch he must have hung out
and going what who have i picked you
and sure enough tiny thought rang me up
and then i had to tell my bosses like
hey um
yeah i'm going to finish up work in two
weeks so i'm going to play for crusaders
yeah
true oh that's hard case robbie dean
he would have been i probably probably
still think
that he knows a muppet
but that's one thing you've always been
known for throughout your career is your
ability to just say what you think or be
yourself like you've never really held
back with your feelings or what you
what's on what's on your mind you pretty
much say so you're always like that even
back then
yeah yeah yeah it's been
sometimes to my detriment but um
yeah i've always been like that mate and
you know i know i've rolled a few
coaches up but uh
we got there in the end mate yeah and
what was it like going into that
crusaders environment
mate it was awesome it was uh
like i say every kid um
south of wellington
and basically north of uh alexandria
wants to be a crusader
if you're playing rugby yeah so
um i was just in awe for quite a while
there and i just put my head down and
wow
like i said i still said what i thought
and got told off for it um i think
guys like leon mcdonald rangy was
playing back then yeah and he'd just be
like shut up bam you know
um
and that was good for me because uh
you know those boys taught me a few
things
yeah
but it was it was a dream come true like
i said and uh
really grateful for that opportunity i
remember day billing for them
and my first ever scrum
i was in johannesburg and i got a tight
head i just was that pumped up i just
pumped the scrub
and i remember flinny saying
[ __ ] horse you better settle down with a
high altitude here you'll blow out
did you blow out no they only gave me
about seven minutes
enough time to pump somewhere and scrum
and run around and clean a few ruts and
she was all over that was the debut so
why why why'd you move the crusaders
because you only played a couple of
games for them didn't yeah so what was
the reason behind the behind the move
oh mate
it was a factory back then probably
still is yeah i had four all black props
in front of me and you only played three
back then there was none of this two on
the bench and
they were fairly step well they were
really good props um
and i being a young and patient guy
there was there was also props
white crockett and
uh ben franks and greg somerville and
um campbell johnson like they were
stacked dave hewett yeah they were
stacked and i thought there is no way
i'm getting in the top three of those in
the next five years and probably
wouldn't have yeah
um
so
i wasn't openly looking but i remember i
didn't even have an agent mate i was and
then
someone said oh you need to get an agent
and i was like oh
right oh so i went and met warren alcock
at a um
some hotel and bloody christchurch and
he
he reckons when i walked in he was like
there's no way this guy's not playing
super rugby next year like he's a giant
and um
he basically got me he just was like he
must have rung every club every
franchise and go look i've got this guy
you probably haven't seen him bugger all
but his name has been man he's 130 kilo
prop so
i went to the chiefs and
in waikato so were you playing you're
playing for tasman at this time
yeah 2006 i played for tasman the
inaugural uh tessie marcos yeah number
three tasman marco number three yeah
absolutely loved it there mate i that
was there was another big big highlight
of my life playing for tessie because i
played for nelson bay as i grew up
there and
you know when i was playing for nelson
bays we had massive battles with
mulberry that was the big there was a
battle of the bombays and the bell of
the bridge it was that was that and um
the next minute were amalgamated yeah
and um i was always going home i was
like yeah i'm here home to do that that
sounds cool they were throwing a bit of
cash around him too so let your mind
through your through your all sorts
yeah
he said i'll give you 40 grand and i
just dropped the phone i was like yeah
i'm there
and you were pretty you were a pretty
loose unit back then too you had all
sorts of mates like twisty and stuff
probably in your hair but my any loose
stories from your time at tasman
mate funny story about twitch because
twisty played tighthead prop for
mulberry when i was playing lucid props
for nelson base
and he was a little maggot anyway we're
playing this game and he's he's just an
awkward little guy to scrum again scrum
against
and anyway i was getting pissed off and
i was a bit loose when i was a young
fella and i said to um i said to twisty
i didn't know
i said oi if you keep doing that i'm
going to punch you in the head
and then nick's grummy did this thing
like rolled his shoulder and we
collapsed so anyway i said to big gavin
briggs he was the he's a stalwart in
nelsonville he's like legion of nelson
mays he plays hooker and i told him i
said look i'm gonna have to sort this
guy out and he goes yeah now do that
it's like we we had a scrum
and i managed to keep twisty up this one
time and then i just stood up
and
got just a massive left hook straight in
the temple and he he just went duff and
dropped
face flat
on the paddock and i went i was shocked
i was shoes and i ran off i just took
off thinking i'm in so much trouble here
this is like a npc on tv
anyway trusty gets stretched off
he doesn't know where he's at
and um he hits me up after the game and
he was like oh that was look at look at
the massive vegan we ended up being best
mates pretty much from that day forward
and then he got named in the tasman team
with me yeah
so
that was sort of the next time i've seen
twisty but um oh
tazzy mate it was
she was pretty rough and ready that
first year
bit like uh you know when a new
franchise starts up the sun wolves and
then it's all good fun and until you
start getting pumped every week
i mean we had cheerleaders and fireworks
for our first game we thought we'd crack
life
yeah they didn't last long
no no they didn't last long neither did
the um neither the decent wages
so
but that wasn't why i left i obviously
back then you couldn't
uh
to be a chief i had to sign for why keto
because the crusaders could they would
yeah
your franchise got first pick of their
mitre 10 cup teams
so
in order not to end up back at the
crusaders which i thought wasn't my best
option um i just went for waikato so i
could stay up there you were one of the
old dogs at um tasmania but you must
have been young because i remember you
and twisty roping me into the room one
time and tying me up and chucking a
blanket on me and doing all sorts to me
but you must have been i felt like you
were 30 back then because i was i think
i was 19. but you must have been like
what
what mid-twenties yeah yeah now i was
yeah i wasn't even mid 20s when i was
when i started at tasman
i think did i play two years there
i think yeah you must have 607 maybe
because i played 30 something games for
them so i must have played a couple of
couple of years there
um
yeah didn't i put your bike up on the
scoreboard
that's right i wasn't even sure it was
you but now i knew it was somewhere
yeah yeah
i spent well i should have probably
spent more time sorting out my footy
than playing pranks on everyone but
um
remember the time we put the deer
carcass in
in the front seat of the um
of the
solidwagon well i think it was jack
lambs or something
belted up the deer in the front seat
put it hooves on the um steering wheel
yeah
yeah we were
she was pretty uh it was great times
down there mate but yeah i was only sort
of early twenties here and it was um
oh just eleven the living the days of my
life it was awesome
yeah so then you talked about your move
up to waikato why that happened and then
what was it like going into the chiefs
obviously a few good lads up there as
well
yeah really enjoyed my time at the
chiefs uh it was a good growing
grow up sort of stage to me because i
got thrown in the mixer i've gone from
crusaders
having to play every now and then with
the best players in the world to
nathan white got a back injury and i had
to start at tidehead and i'd never
really played tighthead yeah um and i
wasn't that good at it back then i was
just a big body um
so i had to learn really quickly up
there and uh yeah it was good fozzie was
the coach back then and
um
he probably pulled his hair out about me
but i was actually quite raisely at the
chief so i had um
the infamous um
line break and the dummy chip to digby
iona who fell for it so i carried on and
a bit of a goosey on um
quentin shivkoski or whatever his name
was and
yeah i'm glad you brought that up
because that was one of the most popular
questions that came in for you talk
about that talk about that run that was
one of the greatest runs we all sort of
have a moment in our career where things
just happened for you and that was your
uh one of the great ones
i've literally there was a hole about as
big as a bus in the middle of the field
and liam messen's just put the ball in
and i've had it at pace
there's one guy standing there and it's
digby ionian
for some reason i must have been doing
it at trainer scene and i've just dummy
chipped and he's put his arms up
and i've just carried on run straight
past him pretty much like this is
unreal and um
yeah it was
yeah what was that guys
he was an ex-leaguer yeah
and i knew he could tackle so i didn't
want to run straight at him
so i did a bit of a swerve and then
tried to goose him
and he managed to get tangled up in my
legs and i fell short by about
i don't know two inches of squaring a
try
oh you went back to your old bullet days
back at second five just pulling out the
absolute brazzle
yeah
sadly that's pretty much where the resu
ended in my career
i did a knee
i did i did my acl the next year i think
it was in yeah 2009 and
there wasn't much razor left in me when
i came back from there
she was more he was more focused on
holding scrums up in the graft
yeah how hard was that injury to come
back from oh it's huge mate it took me
i missed 2010 season completely
um it was a pretty bad rupture i bent my
left foot right round and sat on it
basically
uh and then i so i was coming back okay
after surgery um well first of all they
didn't think i'd done my acl so they
made me rehab for four months and then
play
and i was playing going this is no good
like i literally can't feel my foot
so anyway i got an mri and ended up
getting surgery but yeah when i was
coming back from that i
prolapsed it just trying to do squats
and in my back and i was just a cluster
of nightmares but um
it was all good came back after that and
played another
12 years
and still going strong you mentioned
squats there and that's always been a
big part of your training hasn't it you
always love a big heavy squat
yeah squat to your die man twisty used
to say
um and we used to say that you get uh 20
crossover to your upper body
is that a true stat i don't think so we
used to tell wayne taylor there
we had uh i had squat costumes and all
sorts i just loved i just loved a good
school and i
it became more of a um
it was almost like a party trick
massive squats not doing the trainers
program and all the all the young guys
are watching
oh we must have to do squats ben mae's
doing like 240 260 squats every monday
and it just it was just a nightmare for
trainers because obviously squats have
uh be all an indoor of a gym session
and will you still squat like when you
finish like or is this just a rugby
thing no i think you have to mate when
you're a prop because uh
you know we've got big upper bodies you
don't want little pencil legs once
you're finished
you'll end up like me
yeah yeah
i'll definitely squat i've actually
bought a um
gym
home gym set up because of covered and
i'll probably put that down the cow
she'd um when i get home
mate you're gonna queue and just keep
playing i can see it i can sense it
yeah well it would be quite a strange
stick because i've actually touched wood
got zero injury
issues at the moment
it'll be a cool step to play to 45.
i just don't think i'll find anyone to
sign me mate
mate there's always a shortage of props
the props are always going down eh yeah
yeah
stay fit stay ready yeah but did you
have much success um on the field at the
chiefs
like post your injury yeah we
the year we made the final
who was that well that might have been 2
000
[Music]
we got rolled by 70 over in pretoria
versus the bulls but everything up until
that was phenomenal
um
but no i obviously played new zealand
maoris a lot
every year um since about 07. i think i
debuted for them um
it was yeah
we didn't have well pretty much the year
i left the chiefs won it back to back so
maybe that's um
you set the foundations yeah exactly
what i like to say
talk to me about the maori so we just
had elliot dixon on a few weeks ago he
obviously spoke about a few loose yarns
about his maori times but
you were obviously before him as well
like well before him so it must have
been even looser back in your day
oh man it was
yeah i don't know where it came from but
i remember my first tour
what happened yeah it was just because
back in those days the dd's if you
weren't playing you'd go out
the night before the game
so
i mean we had some nights that we didn't
even get home
in time for the game
and i had i didn't know what was going
on i was just doing what i was told you
know
um
and it's obviously all changed now but
um
yeah i can't remember mate we've had
some real loose now i remember this one
time
jamie joe was coaching and he literally
said to me i must have been a senior
player by then he says he says to me and
pig eaten
pig
we just got off the plane in london
pig
saw the boys out tonight which means
take the boys out on the raz
yeah so we go do an all-nighter as you
do in the in the maori
and then we hit and then jamie joe's got
this meeting at 7am
the next morning so we roll in there
dusty as he doesn't turn up so someone
has to go get him
he's asleep
he comes down
brother's
on the bus
so we're on the bar slope oh what are we
up to we've just been on absolute bins
that he told us to go on yeah boys are
still cut
and then we get to the ground
maintenance is stodgy english
wet
you know terrible muddy ground
and he just starts the tr he gets the
trainers to warm us up and then he takes
over mate he's just we're doing we're
doing a like an hour long military jamie
joe
session and we the boys
carlo blew his calf out
and he's just yelling at the physio
what's wrong with him what's wrong with
him physio's like no no good he's not no
good to me
get rid of him
he doesn't play for the rest of the
tiller
ross felipe did his back
he doesn't play for the rest of the
tiller and we're still and the guys are
dropping like flies i'm still pissed
i'm just getting through it because i've
always been
pretty good at fitness sessions
and i'm looking around going this what
is this this is battle for survival of
the fittest here oh that was jamie's
joe's like way of
you know starting off
off a maori's tour
we literally had 21 guys that were fit
to play for the first game
yeah it was phenomenal but um
yeah other than that
good times
did it get much more professional as the
years went through because you were
you're obviously in that side like you
said for probably about 10 years
yeah it definitely did mate it's not
quite like that anymore still have good
fun but yeah
the maori rugby definitely brings out
like it even made me resley in my later
years because it
just oh you know the culture and
and the [ __ ] papa and everything that
you learn about it's it's pretty cool
mate it's a there's a there's a long
lineage of
maori rugby and
that goes right back in and we get so
gagged up for games on it and we just
get told to pull trigger and there's
there's no better you know the feeling
when you get told you're allowed to pull
trigger
with not many repercussions it's pretty
cool footy
and um i had some good games for the
maoris uh i remember i scored two tries
in one game
against ireland
over in uh
oh it might mean exeter's home ground
which was pretty cool
back when um
angus mcdonald was playing and guys like
that there was some yeah
yeah so um awesome awesome team to be a
part of um
you're hoping to make carth i'm pretty
sure they're playing ireland here in new
zealand this year so i'm pretty sure
i'll get being that team
mate stay fit stay ready
i've got no chance
uh it'll be good maybe i'll get called
up might be a scrum liaison or something
right you'll be in there after your
performance in the weekend you've still
got it yeah
but then uh the move to the hurricanes
from the chiefs why was this move
uh well my man got crook and i was
driving from
uh hamilton all the way back to merchant
center to just with the ferry it was
taking oh wow it was a killer
islander
and i thought oh
bugger this you know i did a season of
that night
of this so i actually rang mark hemmett
direct
and just i didn't tell the agent i just
you know me i just one day i was like
why am i driving all this way and
it's a rung mark him and said oh hey gun
hammer it's been may here um
i see you coaching the hurricanes next
year and i didn't know of all the
controversial well he was coaching them
at the time 2011 this was oh yeah and i
didn't really
know all the controversy that was going
on there at the time and yeah um
i said oh
you know i told him my situation said oh
but wouldn't one come and play for you
and he was like
what with arrogance
yeah i want to come play for you
so anyway sign me up and um
hear the rest sort of history
did you know i'm from the crusaders
oh not really nerves yeah yeah i just
got his number and rang him
[Laughter]
well it was a smart decision yeah it was
mate it was it was um it was awesome too
2012 it was a big um
i won't say
well it was a sort of a rebuild year
well we lost a lot of experience in 2011
and
we had a really young side in 2012 and
you know young cozy and a young jeremy
thrash and a young brad shields and
you know young myself really i didn't
have a clue i wasn't that good at
anything yet um
but we just hooked in and
it was cool
and you moved in with um big jason eaton
a favorite of the wonderland listeners
what was it like living with him
right it was a massive experience it was
um
so
yeah jason eden has heard him on your
podcast actually he's a he's old school
he um got
sort of taken under his wing by andrew
hall at an early age
who's a bloody top man and uh he's older
school
he's um
yeah andrew was a top man so
um pig sort of did that
um
he sort of taught us that sort of um
i guess lifestyle
and
then there was a young bowdoin barrett a
young richard buckman in a
medium
middle-aged being may
um
and we all lived in this in jason eden's
house out in uh kendall
um
geez we learned some things
go on
would you like me to allude yeah go on
let's hear it
so
so
pig wouldn't let us go home after gains
we had to go to the um east
establishment bar
because
he knew the owners and
not that we were you know we didn't
fight him on it we were like yeah cool
and we he literally wouldn't let us go
home till 6am till the sun come up and
he you know so anyway then we'd roll
home he'd order we'd go through the
drive through at mcdonald's head order
like
35
cheeseburgers and every sunday you'd
wake up and there'd be 32 cheeseburgers
sitting on the lounge floor
and we never ate the frigging thing
sometimes i'd put one in the microwave
if i was real hungover
and eat it the next day and then
so that was that and then head order for
like a mid-afternoon snack slash dinner
would be like 12 house pizzas
and that was our dinner slash all day
grazing
and then it
and then he'd tell us on monday
uh don't let anyone know that you've
been drinking and you better front
we're like
yep
right oh pig and we'd be like we'd be
ruined we'd just play we've all played
80s back then because you don't like it
wasn't you didn't like have subs
and we'd be playing 80s week in week out
than drinking till 6 a.m every weekend
it was just i don't know like you look
at rugby now and think about
you wouldn't you could not you wouldn't
do that now no recovery
right and that was our flat for the
whole year i mean it was phenomenal and
then when we came back from overseas
trips we'd have to get our
quota of spirits
and then we'd have um
that'd be like pre-drinks to before we'd
go do things so we'd we'd shoot back to
the flat and we'd have to drink we'd
have teams like mini golf teams in the
house
so it was normally me and bodhi versus
pig and buckman
and we'd have to drink this bowl of
spirits between in our team
when w wherever we lost and oh mate we'd
turn up to social things just plastered
it was
it was some flatmates it was phenomenal
hey hell of an introduction for bodhi
first year playing
so he's not an old man in the state he's
first year just
green and this is how he's getting shot
in the ropes
and um
didn't need any encouragement but oh my
god both absolute great players and
literally while they're living in that
situation we're never going to find
their full potential
that's loose
and any other moments in your
hurricane's career that stand out for
you
yeah obviously the final um well 2 15
when we didn't win the final was uh i'd
just come back into the side and 2 15's
i went to japan for a couple years and
yeah it was
that was tough that was tough
and then when we run it we were always
going to win it in 2016 because we had
we had gary gilton the big chip on our
shoulders from 2015 and no one was going
to get near us i mean the last three
games of that season in 2016 no one's
got a dot against us yeah
well
there's no one beating us
so um
that was kind of cool it was a cool
feeling too because
i remember playing the final and i was
starting
me uh cozy and lonnie the beer the
tongan beer
and um
i actually wellington really turned it
on for us that night and um you were
playing oh yeah
yeah and it was the coldest
shittiest sideways windiest crappiest
night and these boys had flown from
africa
the lions had flown into into playing
this and i i pretty much knew driving to
the game we're going to win this final
we were so well drilled too
and no one had scored a dot against us
and we weren't changing anything so yeah
as a player you're like well all i've
got to do is what i did last week and a
little bit better maybe and no one's
gonna touch us so they're not gonna
screw a try and sure enough they didn't
yeah and they tried uh early on and we
just they they actually tried they
kicked the ball dead
off the first kickoff so they could do a
scrum to try and pump us that was their
weapon deliberate deliberate yeah and um
obviously that didn't work for them and
then about three scrums later
we pumped them
and their locks started blowing up at
their props because obviously that was
their plan for the week yeah and the
locks are blowing up and afrikaans at
their front row that causes just given a
spray because we've ended up on top of
them and um
that was pretty much them done and i
remembered for feet are getting a hold
of yanches a couple of times and that
was the end of them they were they just
wanted me i'm pretty sure if you see of
the rest you know lads you want to
finish this up at 60 they'll see
yeah i remember their nine doing box
kicks in the warm up and one like
backwards for him and he just looked at
me like oh no this is not good for me
you know they're playing scrum penalties
um box kicks in in mall line out malls
and we blitzed every one of them and
then the weather did the rest so
uh there was a big there was a massive
part of um
it was just a big achievement because
we'd
built that team since 2012 and we were
basically rookie no ones um
at the time but then we had obviously
julian savior and arty savior and tj
pettiner and bowden barrett by the time
we got to 215 216 we were
a good side yeah yeah and did you play
in the lions game yeah it did yeah we uh
i think we drew that yeah what was that
like especially for a front rower yeah
cool i'd already had a crack at them
with the with the maoris and oh yeah uh
rota vegas um
and we actually lost that game i think
we spent more time on the haka and the
uh
and all the other stuff
than we did
sorting out the game plan and they they
beat us um
but my ear to play against the british
and irish lions is is another thing that
you don't dream of doing when you live
in murchison as a kid
i mean that's just rock star stuff
though i mean i remember watching dan
carter in 2005 as a fan yeah the year
before i'd played any decent footy
really and um
water the lions 2005 when dc just
lit them up
was um
was something special and then to be
able to play them twice in my career was
phenomenal
and then you know they what do they come
once every 12 years
there's guys that won't even get a get a
look at them so it was cool
and were you ever close to being an all
black you're speaking about scrummaging
against the lions and stuff did you ever
get feedback about um or how close you
were to becoming an all black yeah i had
a couple of um good
meetings with all black coaches but the
obviously 2009 before i did my knee i
was must have been in the running i had
meetings and
i had work ons and things um
and then again it might have been 2012
but
yeah it's hard to know i don't
looking back now i don't know if i would
have been good enough
um i've never been
real top of my game
but i you know i have really good games
sometimes but um
yeah i don't know they're
all blacks are all blacks for a reason
mate they got x factor in that which
i don't really believe i
have x factor
but um
no yeah so i don't know
but
would have would have enjoyed
getting the opportunity and the
challenge but um never came so
don't regret it was that the reason why
you moved to japan or was that part of
the reason you weren't quite getting a
look in from the all blacks and you
thought this was your time i actually
had preconceived ideas that you were
supposed to go overseas when you're
about 30.
yeah
so i sort of just rang wazzer
in ports and said oh
30. so um
do you want to have a look overseas for
me and they came back with
you know because 30 as a prop gun
overseas is pretty uh yeah you're quite
marketable
yeah yeah and i was gonna go to france
actually and then um
yeah and then thank god i didn't
i would definitely would have been would
not have been playing on the weekend
they would have killed me over there um
and then just on the
you know we're sort of sorting out
contracts in that and then um
ports of strings because hey man i don't
know if you'll be interested in this and
no props ever gone to japan to play
rugby but there's enough there's a club
that wants you to go there yeah and it
was jamie joseph's club actually and the
sonic's blues and i was like
oh no
and then anyway she's all have a think
about it and i had a thought about it
and i was like oh i'm going to go to
france and just week in week out get
honed out by angry french
and big georgians and like
you you earn your money in france as a
type of prop like you got to be good um
or go to japan and
who knows you know
see how you get on
you'll either be a raging success or a
failure um and so i went to japan yeah
and that was i actually um played out
the season at the canes and then i was
off pretty much straight away as you do
and i remember sitting on the plane
flying to tokyo
and i hadn't even given the language
barriers a thought
and then i
i thought
geez i'm pretty sure these blokes over
here don't speak english and that
and then sure enough i went to a
non-english speaking club
and i'd had no i didn't even know how to
say konnichiwa like i didn't even know
oh my god
did you have a translator
in the team that could speak both bryce
robbins and harry markety so they said
it was
it was just the first couple months was
real
yeah look i couldn't even i remember
going to the supermarket once
and oh i put all the stuff on the
counter and she might she i found that
later she all she asked was do i want a
plastic bag in
japanese no i couldn't
i couldn't answer so she she didn't
she didn't give me my stuff and i didn't
pay and then i just walked off
you know some i'm like oh off the
neckers
i couldn't even get food it was such a
sideshow
oh my so i had to uh luckily
after that
i got um one of the young guys um
that he could he'd been
he'd been in new zealand and he could
speak both and yeah so he took me to the
supermarket
uh it was a battle mate she was hard
times
and what was the footy like because
obviously it's it's grown a little bit
from when it was back then to what it is
now it's a little bit more of a
different beast but what was it like for
you as a prop going over there then oh
mate i went real good in the first game
because i'd only played super about a
week ago
i was listening against panasonic and
then
yeah sort of slowly slipped
slipped down the uh
my skill level must have slipped a wee
bit but um yeah it was cool it was good
plenty of plenty of running and
got a bit of ball carrying and things
that i wasn't used to back at super and
um
it was really cool cool culture as you
know
you were at coke and
um
great we were just down the road from
each other so it was
it was an awesome part of fukuoka is a
awesome spot if you ever get to go there
and um
yeah just really enjoyed the lifestyle
uh the food the people
and uh it was a good really well i think
was really good for me
as a human just experiencing something
like that yeah were you just living by
yourself
yeah
yeah i had a four bedroom pink house
apartment
yeah it was
it was a
weird time
weird time
i remember buying a 150 cc vespa scooter
that i didn't know you weren't allowed
you had to have a license and i just
drove around on that i got pulled over
by the police i couldn't speak japanese
and they rang my club and the club's
like
being said
no scooter no scooter and then i'd turn
up the next day on my scooter like
i had a bloody surfboard rack on the
scooter and
uh mate she was the sideshow they would
have been like cheers this guy's an
absolute nightmare
like that language barrier is tough
especially when you get rattled like
things like that with the police and the
supermarket
you're like all i had to say is
uh hate or
no
it's because they speak so fast
i know but that waved the bloody uh
plastic bag in front of you like yeah
but she just stood and did nothing like
blank face i was like
we're done this transaction's over
and then how hard was it with your rugby
coming back to super rugby after playing
a couple years in japan was that hard
especially for a prop
oh hugely it took me 12 months mate i
came back
i actually came back
i was i was coming home to retire
actually i'd had enough over there yeah
and i didn't have a wife or anything
so i was coming home to find a wife
uh at 32
yeah and i was like well i'll go back to
the farm and
sort of yeah i'm done
yeah and just before i came home i think
chrono rang me and was like mate what
are you up to i said oh i'm on my home
i'm done
he says oh
mate we need a prop can you fly in
straight to auckland and we'll pick you
up and then you play this pre-season and
then we're off to
joburg we're off to africa for three
weeks and if you go right in the game
you can you'll be coming
oh yeah
oh you've got no one else still never
misses
i don't even know if i told my old man i
was going home and um
so they picked me up from auckland
airport i'm playing against tony
woodcock one of the og greats of our
game lucid and
oh my god no so literally no trainings
with the hurricanes we go out to
some park in auckland and play
and i managed to hold woody out for 25
minutes
chrono's like
job done you're on the plane
well i'm off to africa
three weeks with the boys
um
but
you know answer that i ended up yeah i
think i got a blood clot or something i
it against the lions and that's right i
think i might even have dished up the
lions first scramble i was only got a
tight head and chrono just thought this
is awesome and then i had a um
i had a uh i got a blood clot from the
flights because i've flown pretty much
i pissed up in
japan because i was never coming back so
i pissed up hard for two days jumped on
a flight straight off the flight played
a game and then i'm back on a flight
i ended up getting a blood clot in my
calf
um but yeah it took me oh
a good 12 months to get back to where i
needed to be as a prop playing super
rugby in new zealand after being in
japan and i think you see the same with
like gaza big brody retalic and
it's a big
uh physical
change in just yeah she's tough tough
gig
yeah mate that's crazy that's crazy your
um story there about coming back to the
canes because i remember you being what
you must you're 32 you're one of the old
dogs and it felt like you were thinking
about retirement didn't know it was that
close but look at you seven years later
still going unbelievable mate absolutely
crazy yeah yeah and then
yeah it just sort of
yeah i don't know what happened but i
ended up signing contract after contract
one-year gigs for the next seven years
and you changed provincial regions a lot
during that time as well you had
wellington hawkesbury oh yes so the
first year
uh
i just ended up staying well because i
met crab i met kirsty oh yeah yeah
um through through bodhi
so i ended up staying in wellington
because she was in wellington so i
thought oh i don't really care i play
yeah i'll just stay here and um so i
stayed in wellington and then
um
i don't know how i ended up at hawke's
bay for five years but
some reason i went up there
which was awesome actually i love talks
man i met some really good guys and
yeah i still keep in contact with all
those boys up there it was it was a real
good fit for me hawke's bay yeah um
just a good country
sort of vibe and they just go hard and
they love malls and big scrums and it
was just a great fit for me at the age
of that i was and
yeah now it was cool up there so
um
i actually
i mean i played for taranaki about a
year ago yeah
i moved up to taranaki to uh to sign off
and that was that was me thinking you
know i'll give back i'll give a bit of
so i'll do a bit of coaching and playing
and yeah
um ended up winning a bloody he ended up
playing the all blacks for the ram
philly shield
canterbury
for some i don't know how canterbury
managed it but they had every all black
that they had possible could play played
against us in a shield game that's right
um actually got quite a good yarn about
that if you want to hear it yeah oh mate
of course so
it's shield week
taranaki versus canterbury
and we they have their whole black team
moody
toady tail you name it they've got it
sam white like richie moana yeah they
just bridgey was on the wing they were
just unbelievably strong
and i thought they must have always must
have been on on a break
and then so we got bodie and uh geordi
not scott just body and geordie yeah
and um
so we're like right
okay well we're hitting the christchurch
for the shield so we you know shield
weeks are a little bit different might
attend cup you know it's a bit of a it's
a thing and that you make it
which is cool too for the young guys
because it is a completely different
beast like you throw the kitchen sink at
that game to win it you know
anyway so bo and jordy come back we go
to golf on um
on the wednesday as you do
and we turn up the golf and there's um
there's a 24 box
and of of um i think it was waikato
draft and each
cat
and so we felt obliged to drink them
because someone put them there for us
so we drank so we drank basically
12 bottles each on the round
of golf on 18 holes
and we thought it'd be a good idea we
went back to because i was living down
the coast of taranaki and in kirsty's
hometown i will call him there
um
and have a beer we ended up there pretty
much
half most of the night
so we had to start my house
pulled out the ear beard pump that up
boat is on the couch
and um no no bodies on the single bed in
the baby's room
um
we've ended up having quite a large
night which is not
good but we did
it's done now and um so we we woke up
all three of us and thought geez we're
gonna have to front today so i cooked us
a big feed of sausages and eggs
and we we
headed into training
and someone says to me we're in the
huddle and someone says
she was drinking
like it smells like a brewery
and i was just like trying not to
breathe y'all
you know dunno
having thursday training you know what
they're like just full contact we're
lighting each other up and it's just and
then it's just straight home for
recovery before before captains run
anyway
we head down to um
we head down after captains run to
christchurch and we park up there and
i'm back as soon as we get off the plane
back to bed
just trying to get the carcass right and
then we
we turn up there on game day
and it's a it's a big old match like
we've got all black versus all black all
across the park and we are just into it
and lighting each other up and it was a
great game we ended up
winning
so then we're back on the pass for the
shield and no we haven't told anyone
what we've been up to
but um
you know we sort of let the cat out of
the bag about 4am the next morning what
we've done and that that was the secret
to winning the shield
oh my that's crazy that was cool and you
you had a few good um shield ones too i
remember one in particular when you're
at waikato yep and um i was at taranaki
and we'd go on the whole season without
lose holding that shield and then you
guys come spoil the party right for the
summer unbelievable game from i think
yourself and tim mickelson from memory
absolutely run amok right we had it we
had we hadn't hardly won a game all
season so we
i remember having a cup of tea the night
before the game with uh weka yeah craig
clark
and basically
he sort of felt sorry for us and i sort
of agreed with him that we were no show
yeah because we knew each other since we
were young and it was sort of like a
gentleman's agreement that
you know yeah we've had a rough year and
he was like yeah it's been tough to
watch and
basically
over a cup of bill grey agreed that
we've come down here and nothing's going
to change
and um
20 minutes into the game timmy
mickelson's already scored four dots
and we and we i'm just
looking across we're about to do a scrum
and i'm thinking
we're on here lads and we're on top like
where everything's coming off for us and
then we started pumping your scrum and
pig eating throwing punches and james
brought his just blah and i was just
loving it i was interested i was in a
bloody um i thought i was in a dream it
was that good and we we ended up taking
the shield i think we scored about 40
points and
uh took the shield back to work today we
played one game against hawke's bay and
uh that was the end and we had the
shield for the summer and geez did we
make the most of it
what's it like holding the shield for
the summer oh phenomenal mate you know
what it's like you uh you take it to
barbecues yeah
you do all sorts of shenanigans with it
um it ends up it's for some reason
always ends up in a fire somewhere like
it ended up in the fire at spain's aisle
house and we're all just ah yeah you
just what are we doing like this thing's
legendary yeah
um but we do silly things with it and um
i mean i i
seriously to this day my shield
um experiences are probably
you know they're right up there with the
best experiences of my rugby career yeah
right absolutely hands down
love that thing and what it does for new
zealand rugby and still to this day i
mean it's
it's what we always talk about hey they
are the games you know you don't talk
about so much about winning the finals
or
you know playing against the lions
the other ones when you get around your
provincial you know you talk about the
shield yeah
and um and all the great times you have
with it and
it's just called they made that shield
in your house and stuff because i think
it holds
there's so many great men have had that
shield and played for that shield and
yeah
and you're a part of it and it's yeah
it's
real cool and it's an achievable um
thing for every minor team cup team so
it's
working if the neck you get an early
shield challenge is he putting the boots
back on
but um
no no no i actually talked to neil
barnes today he wanted to know what i
was up to i said mate
i literally have to knuckle down and get
this farming sorted
otherwise kirsten kirsty's dad's gonna
tell me to bug her off i'd say
so is that the plan is that the plan for
you now um get back after the season
after this season get back to the farm
yeah mate yeah i'm looking forward to um
uh hooking into the farm again and just
watching footy
uh
and um
yeah just moving on we need to have some
more kids and
uh i need to rest my 40 year old body
before it uh completely flies apart and
uh yeah i think it's time for me mate
there's
there's some good young guys coming
through
especially at the hurricanes in um
taranaki and
it's my time to
i think i've given
yeah plenty back with my experience in
the last um couple of years um as much
as i can um
whether that good or bad for the team
but
i think yeah it's definitely time for me
to move on mate and i'll just be happy
that i'm still fit um
with with no injuries touched wood and
given given new zealand footy everything
i can and had a good run
you're a legend and speaking of injuries
what's your hit like head like because i
know like carl heyman's obviously come
out front row is obviously a little bit
more prone to
um the
dementia side of things have you had any
um issues with your
brain or have you noticed anything
different from when you started
no it depends who you ask jimmy
i mean if you ask my wife
she thinks i've got dementia and um
and uh what is it bipolar she reckons
um
but i i don't think she realizes that
i've had that since i was about 12 so
um
no mate serious no i i've been bloody
lucky i think um i've had yeah a couple
of head knocks and and that but
maybe nothing like some of my mates like
my good mate reggie and brody and yeah
you know i really feel for those guys
that had to
um
pull pin on their career when they were
just getting started and the big stuff
you know all all black for
broady and reggie wood's definitely
going to be in all black so
real tough to go through that with them
and still be playing at 40 because i
know they must be going what yeah on
earth
then is that and we all got cut short at
25 you know so
um but no touchwood i'm not too bad mate
i am
i think i'm pretty normal
in the head department as normal as i
was ever going to be so
yeah pretty happy so what's what's um
work involved on the farm for you is um
hard labor or
it's um
[Music]
it's milking cows every day oh yeah
and
obviously learning a [ __ ] ton because i
haven't milton cows or we were dry stock
farmers when i was a kid yeah so which
has been a really good challenge um but
i'm pretty well you know
i've got good farm skills from
growing up on the farm fencing and
things like that but
like farming for me is
um
i couldn't do an inside
desk job or an inside any job really
i'm not that kind of guy so
i just really enjoy what farming does
for your family life and your lifestyle
and
it's just me
right up my alley you know
outside and
living the dream really how good and
that's you that's you forever
you think till you retire yeah i don't
think i'll do the coaching mate i
haven't really got um
i can't really
i struggle to get what i'm uh wanting
across
in a in with good literacy yeah
but you got so much knowledge in there i
know a lot of people use you as a mentor
or a coach so
it'd be a shame to not see you in the
coaching scene in some way but hopefully
as maybe a mentor or something for some
of these young props yeah man i'm happy
in that space ask me a question if i
know the answer i'll i'll run you
through it but yeah sort of
coaching um
it's a big gig eh people don't realize
coaches do so much work behind the
scenes i mean they're putting in
14 15 hour days and
they're away from family the same as a
player but they get none of the they're
getting out of the treats yeah
um i don't think people realize that no
that's um
no
and i mean you spend your half your week
on a computer
and then guys go out there and don't
listen to anything you see i mean it
must be so frustrating
you know i mean you've got to like not
blow your stack the next week when you
do the review about what you told them
to do and they didn't do it
and articulate some lovely words to make
them
maybe do it next week so
it's it's a tougher gig than people
think summed it up in a nutshell right
there coaching 101. yeah yeah exactly so
now i'll stick to my farming maiden
hunting we've got the hunting business
as well
um
heli is um
we're we're 50 50 in that hilly does a
lot of the work uh well i'm obviously
playing rugby and milking cows so
yeah thanks for that hilly um but that's
a cool business as well also gets us out
of uh taranaki and down to queenstown
for
a bit of the bit of the year doing that
and
yeah mate how good wait what a career
but as always we've gone to our
instagram for some questions and holy
heck we've got plenty plenty for you
uh first question best watty story
richard what
one of the greats oh wow
um
oh
what's a good body story he's got so
many mate i should've yeah um
the main watty story for me mate was
like he coached me for 10 years
and um
he he's old school and i
used to just break me like
we don't like doing full contact during
the week as a player
and what he would get up there on a like
a month he still saw from the weekend
and he'd be like right boys
we're gonna do line outs we're playing
the germans this weekend which is the
crusaders
and we're gonna work and we're gonna
move them
so we're gonna go out there and we're
gonna
bang bang
bang bang round the corner around the
corner and he would just and then we'd
go outside and just literally tee off on
each other for 25 30 minutes while your
backs are
trying not to look and laugh as you're
just doing like touch
playing touch or something
and no he he did that to me for 10 years
we'd do and i was just like i can't take
another day of this but it was it got us
to where we got to and it was just hard
case but um
yeah there's plenty of crack up water
yarns matey's
i don't know if he's naive or oblivious
to the world sometimes but should he get
some cells in some situations
maybe one thing i have noticed is you're
very good at coaches impressions yeah
it's that's about four of them now that
you've absolutely nailed oh my god you
know yeah
god he is he is the next level coach on
what he's good man
okay good stuff next question
hunting one best hunting yarn cheers
horn oh
well well me and adam hilde have done a
lot of hunting together
um
and a lot of drinking together i
remember one time actually we uh because
i didn't know but i'd asked hely's wife
out on a date when we were young fellas
before they were together
she was a lifeguard at the dunedin um
aquatic center
and uh she was hot she's hot and she was
up on the lifeguard thing and i back
then i was a bit of a lad nothing oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna ask you for her number
and the boy's like kahoe in there now
you won't and i was like
i'm doing it and i walked up to her and
hit her up for her number she gives me a
number and anyway messes me and then
she's in denim i get back to hamilton
i'm like
a couple of messages like this like this
is not gonna go anywhere what am i
thinking didn't message her back
and um
unbeknown to me she had a boyfriend at
the time
who she didn't like he was he was a bit
of a dicky or something so she was
you know maybe i was the replacement so
she messes me back and
anyway
me getting her number gave her the
courage to bim him
and then ended up with the acid man heli
but i didn't know any of this so i go to
japan and i come back and adam hill was
playing at the hurricanes
didn't know the guy from embarrassing
and he doesn't really he's dog on me you
know like he didn't really give me the
time of day and i was like who's this
buddy in a pill led
and anyway
he found out that i was into hunting and
he was keen on hunting so we weren't
hunting together he was like bugger he's
the only guy on the canes at hump so we
went hunting
and then um
i didn't know for a bit so we got a real
house on fire hunting all every day off
and we went buddy shot all sorts of
things and uh
one day we're in a hut
and um
up uh
what's it called oh it's a river up in
canterbury
and we we'd stashed
um tomahawk stakes in a heap of piss
like three boxes of beers and a bowl of
whiskey in this hut and then gone
flowing up to this other heart and it
took us all week to get back to this hut
so by the time we get back there mate
we're not we know we've got tomahawk
steaks beers whiskey we're wearing this
like we're on here you know like weeks
where the walking around and the
southern alps
get back to the heart it's snowing and
we'll just get the fire crank here and
we're into this piss
cooking our steaks and we're playing
cards and
and then he says to me
he's drunk and he's like
yeah you know what i didn't like you
when you first moved to the hurricanes
when you came back to the hurricanes
it's like
now i sort of got the feeling though
he's like
yeah well because she tried to hit on my
missus i was like jeez what [ __ ] mate
i'm sorry when was this
she wasn't even your missus
nothing happened i missed you twice and
then we both were like this ain't
working and um
yeah we ended up having a bit of a
wrestle on the floor and wake up the
next morning we're supposed to be
leaving the next morning
woke up we both slept on the floor and
our knees just
woke up still snowing oh yeah no we
won't be going we won't be
the choppers don't fly in the snow we'll
be sweet so we
hung over
went outside to get our trophies we'd
shot all these trophy ball tar and
they'd been taken away like
they
they were gone
yeah we later found out that
ferrets and that do that when you're at
those huts so we lost our trophies um
long story short we put on the stew
because we thought we were in there it's
all snow there's about a foot of snow on
the ground
we're sitting there like licking our
wounds and then this chopper turns up
lands right outside the hut and we're
sitting around we haven't packed
anything
there's still on the stove oh mate we
chucked the stew out the window quickly
got all that [ __ ] chucked in the shopper
and we're out of there but
it was um
it was a hard case he'd held onto that
for like
two years that i'd dated his missus
and then he hits me up in a hut in the
middle and i went
oh one of the greats one of the great
yards
yeah okay next question yellow card to
game ratio playing for coastal
who just asked that
oh i'm not too sure ah mate it'll be
off cheddar to be high
i've pretty sure all yellow cards in a
season and i only played about six games
[Laughter]
oh good ratio i had a tough run out
there i think um i don't know is there
some sort of taranaki club rules must be
different than super i can't seem to
adjust
i'll tell you a quick yarn about a
yellow card though i'm standing behind
the poles
behind the horns synbind
and
this little guy walks over to me he's
got a hoodie on and he's walking into
the tri-line you know when you're
standing behind the horns and then the
plays you carry on and um i'm standing
and i'm pretty fuming you know i've got
plenty of like the club boys gave me
plenty of lip as i was walking off and
yeah oh big hurricane and
you know this and that and um
you know have fun in the bin sort of
thing and this little weedy guy walks
over he's got his hood on i can't see
his face and he goes oh bummer
up to your old tricks eh and i was like
still pretty pumped up i was like who
that if's this
and also i just thought of some random
yeah
and it was and he comes over pulls his
hood off and there's snakey
ah
and i'm just ready to give him a year
for away i was cracking up it was hard
case it was one of my binning days
so many okay next round this looks like
a good one how do you know nikki watson
ah now regis mates from uh i just met
her actually uh when i was playing at
the chiefs through through another gill
that um
that i knew
okay
which was cool actually because i used
to have a
pull out of sports illustrated on my
wall when i was at boarding school so it
was great meeting
okay
has been ever done a nudie run
plenty
there's actually a few yeah
uh the the um
the hawke's bay initiation is a is a
full field
four corner nudie run
which is uh phenomenal um
i actually um
i never used to go to the hawke's bay in
the season piss-up
being older than that i thought oh you
know anyway so with this one year i got
on the i got on the terps after the last
game pretty bad
at uh
i was living with jeff chris i got on
the terps anyway and then i got home
about 5am and uh crabby won't let me
sleep in her room so i'm in the spare
room nude
and um
i wake up to this noise
and i'm like what that if's there and
it's the boys that got that got the
party bus drove to my house parked
outside and there's 30 of them in my
house chanting
on the bus on the bus and i'm full
stackers and i'll jump up out of bed
run out this dirty dude's standing there
on the bus on that bus and they might
they drag me out and no clothes they had
to borrow clothes i'm full no just
it was um
yeah it was they got me good it was
pretty cool
thankfully i ended up getting some
clothes but uh yeah okay this is more
serious um toughest scrummaging opponent
over the years
oh i had a few um
these are all pretty tough now because
i'm pretty [ __ ] at it um
big white cocky man big what me a bit
crocky have had a few
battles he's had my number most of the
times uh
he never quite managed to work out the
big god croc zilla but um
joe moody's pretty tough uh
yeah
yeah yeah
yep those those are pretty good
cocky's
the number one okay two more questions
this one it's probably around how how
you look so young still does he have any
grays
no for some reason i don't i'm i'm got a
full crop
full head uh lid of here
and no graze
even in the beard which unlike cozy
is um he's pretty much a full silver fox
now i don't know what's going on there
no die nothing no i made i don't put a
lot of time into myself other than a
great moisturizing regime that i learned
um
you know way back
from dc was that yeah it might have been
back in the dc cameron macintyre i think
showed me how to
groom yourself
well it's paid dividends i should have
probably jumped on that well she taught
me that
yeah yeah okay last question best piece
of advice ben may has for woodland
listener
mate just be yourself um it'll
it'll pay dividends in the long run
because uh
yeah i know we they try and shape us
into all sorts of things in this game
and uh
in the long run
you just got to be yourself and and
they'll come around because
they came round to me but it took a good
10 years but
[Laughter]
i think i'm finally fitting in
i i can't laugh a story about that uh
when i came back to the canes this year
there's a new uh
like a social the media girl
bex i don't think she'll listen to this
that's hardcase but um
she she says to me um
i says oh g'day i'm ben
and she goes oh i'm bex i said oh what's
your name she says bix um the marketing
girl she goes where do you fit in around
here i was like you know i've never
fitted in around here
but i just
because i was wearing like my full farm
kit and instead of anything and who's
this old guy started kicking around the
base here um
and now she's probably sitting again oh
he's a hundred game of the old mate yeah
oh that's classic yeah
hey just one thing i've got for you
after my words of wisdom what about the
night we're standing out there uh on the
on the field um
it must have been the last game of 2019
man you're
yeah i can't quite remember yeah you
were warming up i'm pretty sure i was
warming up and we're just having a chat
and uh
this thing comes up on the big screen
and it was a thanks to all the guys that
are leaving and it was like nani lamarpe
and uh
it was you as well wasn't it yeah it
might have been me it could have been me
you're tiring these guys are retiring
and you had like not seen a boo about
retiring you were just injured like you
just had you know
your contract then you were just injured
and then jimmy marshall pops up and you
looked at me and i looked me i was like
when did you uh release that brian
you're like never told anyone right i
wasn't i didn't think i was retiring
one of the great moments i was like oh
it looks like you're off son
and i haven't played since
so they must have known but i do think
you were sort of contracted to tasman or
something and maybe looking at coming
back because you're
not even that old but jeez i had to
laugh yeah mate i definitely didn't
think i was done when that went up there
i was thinking potentially my if my
rehab went well i was going to come back
and maybe try and play
i was i think i was what 32 you were 37
i could get another five years here but
um they called it and yes i'm now done
so
one of the one of the greats a great
moment yeah oh but mate what a journey
what a career and what advice um like
like you said in your advice be yourself
and that's definitely something that you
have lived by i'm sure everyone who's
played with you will
they'll know that um they'll have some
stories about their times with dan may
no doubt because mate you are such a lad
you're a team man for almost every side
you've been involved and you've
definitely left your mark on the game
here in new zealand so it's been awesome
having on the podcast and going through
your journey mate great to finally be
here i won't do another one because the
next one will be pretty boring uh if
this one wasn't boring enough so
yeah mate it was one of the greats
you're a led
to the listeners